لقد حكم عليك بالاعدام برميك من الطابق
التاسع بعد هذه الجمله التي وثقها القاتل
بمقطع فيديو قام برمي قطط صغيره من شرفه
شقته في الطابق التاسع في مجمع بسمايه
السكني ثم الحكم عليك بالاعدام
شرقا لحد الموت من الطابق التاسع
الفيديو اثار غضب العراقيين على مواقع
التواصل ووصف المتابعون الفاعل بالوحشيه
اذ قام بفعلته هذا اثناء تصويره بثلا
مباشرا للقطه وهو يقوم برميها وطالبوا
وزاره داخليه العراقيه باتخاذ الاجراءات
اللازمه بحق فعل مناهض لحقوق الحيوان
[موسيقى]
اقدم الفاعل على الهرب بينما وجه مدير
العلاقات والاعلام الامني في الوزاره
ضباطا من الشرطه المجتمعيه بمتابعه ملابسه
القضيه وذكر ذو المتهم بانه يعاني من
مشاكل نفسيه وانه يتناول الكثير من
المشروبات الكحوليه وذكرت السلطات الامنيه
بانها ستنقل الفاعل الى مركز للتاهيل
النفسي لمعالجته هناك بطلب من اسرته
تم الحكم عليك بالاعدام
لحد الموت من الطابق التاسع